what is do you have a a favorite Miami
strip club you like I've been to most of
them I mean booby trap booby trap's cool
it's just a lot I'm just not a club just
a lot going on there I like I like that
a lot going on Miami period I like
tootsies though TOS tootsies is just
chill you could go sit off in the cut
and have a lobster tail and not be
bothered maybe so to did it you get up
on that second floor you got security
running around the parking lot harassing
you and [__] yeah booby trap's a wild
Place yeah booby trap's fun well I'm
just not a club person I just I'd rather
be in the house playing video games
unless you're getting paid to be there
yeah and Anime what's your favorite
anime my alltime favorite is in
Yasha but I've been liked in to uh Black
Clover I've been locked in my hero
Academia I've been locked in to uh the
new bleach bleach yeah I've heard of
that my son I just bought my son the
sword from uh one piece I bought him a
sword
from I'll tell you right now cuz I
texted him what's your favorite
anime I bought him I spent like two on
Christmas I brought him this [__]
sword from this [__] anime a sword
yeah it's a
um Attack on Titan oh Attack on Titan it
was good I can't stand how it ended it
was [__] he says his favorite character
is amond and my top anime is Dragon Ball
nuto and Attack on Titan dragon ball one
of my tops too they just don't be
consistent no more isn't there like 30
Seasons how do you like I you know what
is is but you got to think all the
episodes be stretched to like like one
fight will be eight episodes see I
didn't know that yeah you know what is
in anime people don't give credit for it
being an anime is The Boondocks it's not
an anime it is it's not it is it's not
see that's it is an anime I mean if you
go off the animate definition is not
what does that mean it's like Chinese
animation it's Japanese I think no it's
not is it Chinese Boondock was made by
uh Aaron mcgruer but it's it's it was
made very you've never seen the fights
in the
Boondocks that's not anime it's an anime
bro The Boondocks is an anime just like
Afro samai Samurai anime so if I call
car he going to he going to say his feel
like his anime yeah Aaron first of all
the guy who created his name is Aaron
mcgruer you like you like The Boondocks
I love The Boondocks I got all the
seasons on DVD me too season 3 was that
was when the writers left I love all
love them season one and two though I
don't think it gets better I got a radio
drop from uh Uncle Ruckus for real yeah
the voice actor was doing drops yeah
like 10 years ago I got it shout out to
Uncle Ruckus
AKA is it safe to say would you say the
closest thing to like a real life Uncle
Ruckus we've seen is Charleston
white I'm not sure it's
close right he said some crazy [__]
about his own people I'm just like
that's
very I was a little uncor
rucky you might be
right got the eye [__] that though he
said he got the ey no offense but you no
but he does he does have the I didn't
even you know what I wasn't even
thinking about that well I think he
really be just doing that for the social
media I don't know what I've seen I met
him before was he nice yeah I mean
listen I've seen a lot of his content
that I think is hilarious and I've seen
a lot of his content that I think is
yeah extremely yeah when I met him I
just told him about like I don't agree
with what you be saying but you say what
you want so you know right is there uh
anybody uh for you that you know you
you've
obviously been on the other side of
being a hot new artist who's who's
somebody who's who's come out the last
year or two that you're just a fan of
doesn't even got to be somebody you know
or there been some dope [__] coming out
lately like big X the plug is hard yeah
I [__] with big X he's hard bro that
Mexican OT um big X be having some nice
beats yes Mexican OT for sure we got I
got uh two tracks on him with OT yeah oh
fire we went hog hunting him and I in
Texas for real yeah we were I told him I
wanted to go we um we were in a
helicopter and the guy lowered the
helicopter we put the guns out of the
helicopter just [__] mowing down pigs
that's F it's on YouTube for real yeah
this [__] is so much fun why you see
that must not be on your channel it's
doing really well no it's almost at a
million views it's on my channel I check
it out it's fun if you ever go to Texas
I always want to do it but I don't know
if I can you can I I'm an animal lover
no I'm saying because I'm a fell oh well
they didn't ask me any questions it's
Texas bro yeah but if I had to sign some
paperwork I can't because if you lie on
there and say that you not the Fon
that's a federal hey we didn't have to
sign nothing right no we just got
straight straight to it just hopped in
the helicopter they handed us a gun
check out there we was mowing down the
over gun yeah just gun safety yeah okay
yeah it's fun just don't film it don't
don't post no pictures I mean you know I
don't it's Texas I don't think in I feel
like they don't give a [__] yeah
everybody got a gun yeah with the F
though they don't give a [__] this is
true they trying to lock up everybody
with a gun so you can't even vote that
sucks yeah I don't really get into all
that yeah I don't really care about it's
not your vot president or not yeah I
always tell everybody this man if if
who's the president has to do with how
successful or happy you are in life you
got the whole game [__] up yeah cuz
I'mma get it no matter who my thing is
if I can't do nothing to change it I I
don't give a [__] about I try not to
give a [__] about it it's like you could
only
control man wake your fat ass up
man he's a
snore he been sleep for a minute but the
snores kicked
in I'm
sorry silly that sounded like your
officer
voice that sounded like what's his name
officer what oh a br stupid a br stupid
bro you should do a [__] skit would
you ever like try to do TV or like I
want to do a cartoon that should be
great I can't find nobody let me do it
you want to like do you want to like
write it and then I want to do a voice
oh you'll find somebody can't find
nobody all you got to do I guess it's
easier in La you got to get a agent on
the actor side and they'll try to pit
you for voiceover Stu how I get an agent
I don't know know some
agents I don't know any agent on the
acting side I'm like the most I mean for
living in La I don't know much on the
just imagine me doing a Disney movie
that to be
fire you wouldn't even you wouldn't even
have to like uh you I wouldn't tell
anybody like yo it's redo bang just like
your government name yeah here's some of
my examples maybe a couple GTA clips of
you playing officer [__] whatever the
[__] and I think I think it's possible
man yeah tell [__] tunji to help you
out [__] yeah yeah yeah
well listen man the album's coming out
when cuz I just saw you put the
pre-order up people could pre-order and
try to unlock the artwork the 19th 19th
how many songs I think like 15 but I'm
uh I'm coming right back in like two
three weeks you really yeah Deluxe or a
whole new album oh I'm a Delux it how
many extra songs six seven I'm still
aside right
now shout out to hey man you got hey I
got a feeling we going to get another
album before the end of the year from
you too I it's [__] January no trying
to get y three this year three okay